I recently went through a divorce that
finished about a month ago it lasted for
about a month and since uh since the
beginning of the relationship and even
beginning of the divorce I've been
paying for the mortgage for all the
bills related to the house and for all
the debts that she's carrying uh right
now plus the three dogs that we used to
have together um you're paying three
dogs that you used to
have so
used why would you be paying for dogs
that you don't have for an
ex-wife because uh since the beginning
of the relationship she basically
decided not to work even if I encourage
her I even pay
her have you got the dogs no I don't
then they're no longer your
responsibility okay if you want to take
care of the dogs go get them but
otherwise quit paying for the freaking
dogs